ce sont cette fois des militaires
d'actifs qui publie cette tribune sur le
site de valeurs actuelles
ces gens qui ont lutté contre tous les
ennemis de la france
vous les avez traité de factieux alors
que leur seul tort est d'aimer leur pays
et de pleurer ça visible déchéance nous
avons connu l'opération sentinelles nous
avons subi les tentatives
d'instrumentalisation de plusieurs
communautés religieuses pour qui la
france ne signifie rien qu'un objet de
sarcasmes de mépris voire de haine cette
déchéance nous l'avons vu dans bien des
pays en crise elle précède
l'effondrement elle annonce le chaos et
la violence de nouveau la guerre civile
couvent en france
et vous le savez parfaitement côté
d'avoir peur d'une guerre civile et
surtout faut-il tirer à balles réelles
c'est vrai que ça c'est un débat qu'on
entend depuis sedan plus et qui nous
fait un peu flipper 1
on va pas se mentir alors faut-il avoir
peur d'une guerre civile moi je me
tourner d'abord vers michel michel vous
êtes l'auteur de cette lettre adressée
au président dont qui a été donc publié
dans valeurs actuelles enfin vous non
pas vous mais là il ya aussi une lettre
publiée mais les verts à l'heure
actuelle ils prennent pas toutes les
lettres non plus est ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir une guerre si mais je
pense que je pense que malheureusement
on y est déjà quand eux tous les soirs
toutes les nuits nos collègues sont
attaquées avec la volonté de les tuer
ils prennent des cocktails molotov qui
sont tirés avec des tirs tendus de
d'artifice il ya une volonté aujourd'hui
tu es les collègues on a deux connexions
lecaron 2e en 12 jours une collègue qui
a été égorgé à l'accueil du commissariat
un autre qui a été tué par un arc aux
terroristes donc aujourd'hui oui on en
guerre si l'hymne qu'il existât police
bashing et que les français ne croient
plus en la justice oui c'est évident on
l'a vu avec la sphère sarah halimi et
français ne croient plus à la justice et
police se bashing permanent aujourd'hui
quand il ya la moindre affaire ya
monsieur cheville à quai sur le plateau
alors ils traitent les collègues de
vermine mais aujourd'hui la justice nana
na na na na la retraite les collectes
des canons meilleurs cieux ses cadres à
déchets dessus et je traite les katas
sensiblement la verrie jeudi par les 100
% l'an aujourd'hui depuis mon combat il
a démarré il ya 90
pour cent de gens bien dans la police
était importante mais pour l'instant la
france espoirs et ça n'a pas été jugée
bien maigre laisser la justice faire et
après vous pourrez mais vu que vous
parlez sans à 100 200 500 tenants et
aboutissants jeu j'étais jeune et je
suis à 114 avait sur les 4 yards
assassin je vous le dis ah bon qu'elle
paierait csps que est-ce que la s e mail
adressé par les cieux si c'est pour me
veut attaquer vous dire ce que vous
connaissez pas vous en parler non mais
c'est parce que vous savez pas ce que
vous parlez le chêne monsieur que ce que
vous dites c'est exact vallée suis
désolé mais michel comprenez bien c'est
aussi les mots d'un papa qui a perdu son
fils mais je suis j'en suis compatissant
mais aujourd'hui il faudrait pas
nombreux malheureusement que les médias
exploitent la souffrance d'un père pour
jeter le prop suture a encore dit
jacques était pas la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on vit une situation qui n'est
plus acceptable aujourd'hui notre
organisation syndicale demande une
réforme de la légitime défense les
policiers ne peuvent pas se défendre
aujourd'hui vous donnez un besoin rites
que vous pouvez ouvrir vous demander à
pouvoir ouvrir le feu sur les fuyards
non on n'a pas on demande aujourd'hui
clairement que dans le thème adopté une
urgence en hurlant sur une réforme de la
légitime défense pour les peaux lui est
abaissé en d'art absolument aujourd'hui
quand nos collègues sont attaquées avec
par exemple des cocktails molotov
il faut effectivement c'est armelle et
létales il faut qu'on puisse avoir un
texte aujourd'hui qui nous permette de
riposter
pareil sur les contrôles routiers n'est
absolument pas normal aujourd'hui des
collègues se fasse on sait dessus qu'on
utilise des armes pour tuer mes
collègues et que mes collègues ne puisse
pas riposter aujourd'hui son quiz on a
absolument besoin d'une sur ce point sur
ce point là est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec michel ou pas du tout sur
ce point là sur le point la légitime
défense est sur le point de pouvoir
rétorqué oui vous êtes d'accord nicolas
sur la légitime défense bien évidemment
je suis je suis d'accord mais de l'autre
côté il ya d'autres choses à faire avant
quand il ya des preuves de formation
aujourd'hui chez verizon
donc on peut pas non plus grand des
petits jeunes car oui mais il ya les
problèmes de formation il ya les autres
les objectifs
d'accord vous me répondez sur légitime
défense mais attend de nyoiseau des
prestations
quand vous parlez d'un bon sens
attention qui est pas les gens qui
s'engagent ils tirent sur le premier
venu vous bernard ou berlin vous
comprenez ce que d'une chaîne là dessus
sur les je comprends tout à fait je
comprends surtout la détresse des
policiers qui est très grave il faut
vraiment s'en occuper parce que là ça va
pas du tout il a belle morini-bosc aussi
oui mais aussi surtout de ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine on ne peut pas ne
pas dire mais oui il faut quand même ils
ne ressentent de
de la loi oui alors si vie pareille je
suis totalement d'accord je soutiens mon
dieu que je me répète fait que cette
période compliquée et fils numérique
alors que pour danser aussi quand vous
entendez ça monsieur de chou vert mais
alors un mot un groupe de 14 15 ans il
vole une mobylette
oui non il fait un délit de fuite on lui
tire dessus et on a mal réel
on n'avait jamais dit ça mais ma saison
j'ai des gens qui nous avait un individu
qu'à voler un porsche cayenne et utilise
ce porche cayenne pour volontairement
shooter un collègue il a effectivement
faut qu'on puisse utiliser là une arme
l' arme à feu évidemment va pas tirer
sur un jeune qui a volé un scooter face
est totalement dérisoire il faut en
aucun cas pu limiter à plus de
synchronisation mais non mais non
consenti ça c'est votre position
aujourd'hui là où il n'y a pas eu à
payer c'est cesser dans le cadre de mes
collègues qui se font assassiner on a
deux deux collègues au carreau depuis
douze jours alors vous ça vous dérange
pas mais nous je suis désolé mais je
suis en vie je suis tout pilote suter
avec la famille d'éric je suis tout cas
que la page et c'est sans merci parce
que on a les mêmes problèmes aujourd'hui
ça je vous en ai des familles en deuil
je vous aurais sans doute d'avoir perdu
un mari un père et un fils mais quand je
suis devenu moyenne chaque jour là par
action la police c'est l'abstraction sa
monture heures je vous dis
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir une
réforme de la légitime défense qui
permettent de protéger des pères de
famille avant la légitime défense
fallait faire régner la justice
quant à green bay 40 des émissions de
dupond moretti depuis des mois échéant
aujourd'hui gelée 17 justice ne
correspond plus aux attentes du peuple
j'essaie d'arrêter aventure en effet
c'était pareil
c'est plus sombre et versez-la jura mais
là il parle de dupont vérité mais ce que
c'est lui qui est en panne à tout le
monde ça normal faut aborder avec sarah
10000 insiste encore sur c'est vrai
qu'elle est en pleine matic où la
justice n'a pas été rendue à exhaler
aujourd'hui il ya une fracture entre la
justice et la population ont mis en
pièce est pas là bas messieurs justice
la facture avec sur la justice on va
tâcher d'éviter coprésident des nouveaux
démocrates
vous êtes indignés pas les tribunes les
tribunes qui ont été faites par les
militaires voilà qu'ils annoncent qu'ils
annoncent le chaos et la violence
contrairement voilà qui disent qu'il va
avoir un chaos qui va dire la violence
ça a été publiée dans valeurs actuelles
est ce que vous comprenez que à l'heure
actuelle accepte de publier ce genre de
tribunes oui mais à l'heure actuelle
c'est dans leur ligne donc ça me donne
pas et donc forcément ils défendent
leurs idées à la limite moi valeur
actuelle de france qu'il veut ils ont
saisi team défense normande a par contre
monsieur moi j'aimais regarder ce qu'ils
disaient avant de venir parce que c'est
important de savoir les noms discute
monsieur eddy pas juste il faut pouvoir
faire la légitime défense quand on se
fait foncer dessus par un 4 4
monsieur eddy faut faire comme au brésil
comme aux philippines clipping vous
savez qui c'est qui dirige c'est le type
là qui dit que les militaires devraient
pouvoir violé trois femmes chacune c'est
lui qui dirige le pays aux philippines
monsieur du pertre
il dit qu'il faut faire comme là bas et
qu'il faut laisser la police faire comme
dans ces pays-là ceci semble en effet
que vous savez c'est ça que vous avez
dit monsieur avait retourné aux cartes
qu'il arrive on laisse parler aurélien
oui je suis totalement indigne et quand
on défend ce genre de position par
ailleurs les gens qui ont fait les
lettres notamment les tribunes dans
valeurs actuelles
c'est plus des militaires c'est les
militants de cyrille c'est des gens qui
savent plus l'armée c'est les gens qui
servent leurs idées politiques
c'est des gens à mon avis aussi
d'ailleurs d'une certaine génération
parce que moi je pense que les jeunes
dans l'armée je n'aime pas du tout cette
mentalité là c'est des gens qui ont
peut-être oublié que l'algérie était
plus française qu'on pouvait plus
torturé certains français comme on
voulait donc oui effectivement tout ça
mais
bon je dis ça je dis tout ça je suis
beaucoup plus inquiète effectivement
d'avoir un de ces jours des gens qui
prennent le pouvoir soit par la force
soit par l'élection parce qu'il faut
rappeler d'ailleurs qu'il tarde était
élu donc tout peut arriver et qui met
nos libertés en danger et qui nous
empêche d'aimer qui on veut nous empêche
de vivre où on veut qui nous empêche
finalement d'avoir la religion qu'on
veut ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup plus que
la guerre civile osc alors un civil je
crois pas les jeunes de ce pays
justement csm tu veux tu donnes denis
directeur adjoint de valeurs actuelles
moi j'ai l'impression que ce que
demandent ces militaires c'est de
pouvoir descendre eux mêmes dans les
quartiers difficiles dans les banlieues
et c'est un petit peu voilà moi c'est ce
que je ressens
vous avez su retirer que passait un
contresens en fait déjà la deuxième
tribune elle vient parce qu'il ya une
première très bien que j'ai fait
beaucoup d'émoi et la traque et des
vieux généraux effectivement où il ya la
ministre va dire que c'était des vieux
généraux en charentaises et ça ça agace
et pas mal de jeunes militaires il c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont répondu dans une
tribune qu'on a publié hier soir
et honnêtement moi ce qui me stupéfait
depuis qu'on l'a publié
c'est le nom de vue s'était alors on
parlait à 2,6 millions de français nord
lui cette tribune et y en a 180 2000 qui
l'ont signé alors vous avez dire que les
français qui voulaient ils comprennent
les mois des militaires juste pages
publié cette tribune parce que vous
savez que ça va faire un buzz énorme
ou parce que vous alors hors délais très
honnêtement quel sens il faut dire la
vérité sur les téléphones moi j'ai un
téléphone sur mon bureau et depuis la
publication de la première tribune
verrou de 0,3 à 0,5 des appels de toute
la france je vous parle pas du standard
du journal et là des gens qui disaient
mais où est-ce qu'on peut signer la
tribune des vidéos et nous on leur
disait attendait c'est une tribune de
généraux ça les regarde et donc on
n'entendait pas lancer une pétition là
dessus et en fait après les jeunes
officiers laon les jeunes militaires ont
récrit une tribune est en fait qu il
avait très peur vu qu'ils sont encore
dans l'armée aujourd'hui d'être viré si
leurs noms ont été publiés
donc on leur a dit écoutez on sécurise
votre anonymat regreté et de l'autre on
ouvre une comme une double comptabilité
et là on laisse les français dira si oui
ou non vous êtes des horribles séditieux
audéoud est fâchant aussi vous alerter
sur un problème de société risque de
guerre civile quand tu avais moi je
pense qu'on est dans une situation
explosive parce que effectivement qu'on
voudrait un policier à avignon qui se
fait tuer à 18h30 en plein centre ville
quand vous avez une malheureuse
fonctionnaires qui se fait à ganges et à
l'entrée d'un commissariat à rambouillet
envoyé sait pas non plus comment dire
les les quartiers les plus dangereux de
rio et aujourd'hui vous avez bové blue à
châteauroux des villes comme ça en
france qui normalement connaissais pas
trop d'insécurité et de plus en plus
valence
vous voyez des tirs de mortiers des
attaques de commissariats donc je pense
que la situation explosive et je pense
que les militaires ont raison d'alertés
sur le degré de gravité de cette
situation
maintenant évidemment c'est aux
politiques de prendre leurs
responsabilités faut pas un putsch faut
pas attiser quand on sait que dans
l'armée où il savait ce que ça coûte
même chose quand je mets la maison mais
l'armée est aussi père qui écrit des
tribunes sais pas si vous les avez lu
ils disent on espère qu'on n'en arrivera
pas là on espère qu'un jour il y aura
pas besoin que des responsables
politiques mais nous appelle sur
effectivement assurer le maintien de
l'ordre politique qui peut faire autre
chose que de faire en sorte que les
policiers tirent sur tout le monde parce
que ça m'aidera personnes ça fera monter
la violence dans les pays où c'est
autorisé les payer des policiers seront
tout aussi tuer que dans les pays moi je
soutiens des policiers aussi ce qui
arrive et l'autre jour un rugby non
c'est terrible simplement pour aider les
policiers pour leur donner des moyens
pour leur donner plus de monde sur le
terrain faut arrêter de démonter la
police depuis bien non mais chez
n'importe quoi répondre si vous voulez
toujours par la question mais il ya un
fait de criminalité des effectifs ça ne
sert absolument rien les tous les
criminels c'est vrai qu'ils sont tous
étaient déjà au moins une deux fois
arrêté le problème c'est que derrière la
chaîne pénale ne suit pas et ces
individus sont automatiquement mis
dehors
ra grèce les fonctionnaires donc on est
dans une scène sans fin que vous pouvez
même vous vous dites faut tirer sur les
gens plutôt que de renforcer la chaîne
canal et non des moyens justement je
vais vous dire monsieur tâche et ma
pensée oui effectivement il faut que la
police ait les moyens de se défendre et
moi j'aurais préféré je vais
certainement vous choquer que ça soit le
narco terroristes qu'ils soient morts à
avignon plutôt que mon collègue c'est
pas ça moi je vous le dis je perds
l'ordre dz de l'ombre en occasions en
france en mai les gens vont les arrêter
ses tirs et un bel et bien sûr que l'on
peut comprendre on peut comprendre pour
accrocher voilà je me souviens il a vécu
un drame terrible et c'est pas pour ça
que ça en fait un un monsieur qui est
devenu un outil fille qui le dit à
chaque fois bien au contraire un fil
passé à côté moi je suis pas tremblant
voilà j'ai pas une envie de tuer mais
d'un autre côté comme le syndrome
non quand tu vois je te vient à comment
je vais faire caisse dans quelle merde
je me suis mis j'ai contrôlé le tout
bien j'aurai vécu moi ça me parait
s'arrêter là mais j'ai vécu ça ce qu'ils
ont peut-être peur monsieur vous avez
vous bien que vous ayez pas dire que la
police est raciste en tant que telle non
mais j'ai pas dit quels étaient ses
citoyens que ce n'est pas le passé mais
ça ne s'est pas dit c'est bien pour ça
c'est pas du tout ce qui vient de dire
eh bien dire show via parce que par
rapport à ce qu'il a vécu et son fils
étaient les policiers savent ce qui
s'est passé en mai avec son pied juste
juste mickey michael moi je vais dire un
truc aussi et et monsieur tâche et
mickaël on peut comprendre aussi que
michael aujourd'hui il arrive il est
illisible par ce qui s'est passé il est
touché il un collègue il a deux
collègues d'ailleurs en très peu de
temps qu'ils sont morts on peut
comprendre aussi l'émotion qu'à mickaël
est aussi la colère qu'il a ça aussi on
peut le comprendre c'est pourquoi sa
conduite mais c'est justement ce qui
donne vie chalonnes jerry kelly lui
aussi moi c'est moins cher à se déplacer
richard et michel par mois mais michel
il est aussi engagé politiquement et
défense ya des idées politiques alors se
dit concédant une grise de marine le pen
mais sur voilà tous les policiers et les
jeunes
par contre vos réponses yeux mon
organisation syndicale est totalement
apolitique et moi à titre personnel j'ai
effectivement été conseiller politique
de philippe de villiers
ensuite en 2002 de marine le pen je me
suis détaché de marine le pen puisque
aujourd'hui je considère que marine le
pen c'est l'assurance survie politique
d' emmanuel macron et vous faites tous
aujourd'hui pour porter marine le pen au
deuxième tour face emmanuel macron pour
faire réélire monsieur macron donc moi
je suis très à l'aise avec l'ajout de
bruxelles
aujourd'hui tous les politiciens de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite vous
utilisez tous la police nationale vous
les utilisez vous utilisez nos collègues
à des fins politiques on ne vous
supporte plus je peux vous dire il ya un
rejet du politique au sein de notre
institution collégiale qui est
absolument énorme d'ailleurs comme c'est
le cas au sein certainement d'une bonne
partie de la population française made
in my et vous dites oui oui en fait il
s'agit ni de faire de l'idéologie ni
d'être angélique mais force est de
constater qu ici même à tpm paix qui est
pour moi une sorte de deux fenêtres de
fenêtres sur la société française depuis
deux ans et la folie en fait on assiste
à une société fracturée violente hyper
crhiv et qui ne se parlent pas qui
s'invectivent où il est question
voilà deux évidemment de violence peu de
violences policières de violences contre
les policiers de ghettoïsation de
communautarisme et force est de
constater que ça va très très
donc oui moi je suis très inquiète
d'autant plus que je lis le rapport de
la cia qui avait annoncé une pandémie
mondiale
parce que vous avez un rapport de la cia
à chaque élection de nouveau président
et donc il avait annoncé éventuellement
une pandémie qui viendrait sans doute de
l'asie force est de constater que c'est
arrivé et parle effectivement de guerre
civile d'insurrection dans les
prochaines années pour les démocraties
comme nous qui sont perte de valeur en
perte de sens est ce que démontre la
tribune aux valeurs actuelles et le
problème monsieur tâche et c'est que je
trouve que malheureusement aujourd'hui
en france le problème c'est que c'est si
on est d'accord avec ces tribunes on est
forcément facho mal en est forcément
raciste et c'est ça le problème parce
que finalement le lot se débat
aujourd'hui qu'il me semble-t-il est
très important et confisqué par les
extrêmes après l'onu main et c'est
intéressant ce que dit ce que dit
géraldine moi quand je vois michel et
quand je vois christian jeu on sent tous
les deux il ya une peine immense des
deux côtés et c'est vrai qu'on se dit
c'est incroyable d'en arriver là je
c'est vrai christian vous vous cesser le
combat de votre vie maintenant oui mais
on fait pas même combat est-ce que c'est
passé par là c'est pareil c'est pas les
deux derniers décès qui ait eu dans la
police qui est qui peuvent vous exciter
ça fait des années qu'il ya des
policiers qui décède
oui mais là on sent quand même une
montée aussi ce que je peux donner juste
arrivé et je suis à 100% pour la police
pas 99% vous le savez j'ai déjà débattus
les deux les deux derniers on va prendre
le cas des derniers ils auraient pu
avoir des kalachnikov sur eux j'aurais
pu avoir aidé mais il aura fallu
quoiqu'il soit dans une bulle pour être
protégé il ya un fait mais qu'hélas il
des gorges il arrive par derrière il
égorge
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous comment
vous voulez faire autrement d'accord ça
c'est la faute des politiques c'est pas
la faute de la police
après vous avez le pauvre le poveri qu
elle va au devant de gaulle dernier
ouais
vos papiers machin loti sans un truc
saint-vil un fêlé en panne il aurait pu
avoir une kalachnikov ils arrivent peut
avoir tout ce qu'ils voulaient tourner
il serait peu fumé pareil vous comprenez
les envies vos pas ce chiffre a sauté
non il faut pas sauter sur scène
permettez jus tout coeur je suis je
voulais dit tout sénatoriaux moi j'écris
un message envoyé à la famille pour
l'orgue à chaque fois il ya un truc
comme ça j'ai créé un message pour dire
que tu n'as pas vu jouer on est de tout
coeur avec eux parce que c'est pas
normal
on n'a pas le droit de tuer des jeunes
on a tué des travailleurs message
entendre qu'il quatre jours citizen
media de jouer avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour la police depuis quatre jours
j'entends on n'a pas droit partir
travailler l'avouer ça ça
cit on n'a pas le droit de partir
travailler et pas rentrer chez soi le
soir mais ce n était pas mon fils il
était vers partie travailler en 1h20 du
matin
il n'est pas rentré le soir qu'est-ce
qu'on garde ces enfants ont aimé ce
qu'on explique bien se payer moins que
monsieur à nous il est où le problème
si je m'en sépare les je vais michel
honda pendez moi je peux pas de toute
façon la position dans ce débat là elle
est malheureusement pour vous n'êtes pas
à votre place dans ce débat là puisque
la faire de votre fils n'a absolument
rien à voir avec le débat
on est en train d'aborder aujourd'hui la
question vos collègues il aurait pas pu
se défendre
pourquoi il n'a pas pu pourquoi il s'est
fait battre mon collègue avignon parce
que justement à force de faire du police
bashing et de limiter les moyens
d'action de la pdt de la police on ne
peut plus intervenir de manière un peu
musclé et prendre des précautions parce
que sinon on doit regarder la police
doivent regarder aller avec les jeunes
ambitieuses et vous avez bien vu les
images c'est s'approche et s'approche de
oui mais pose une question mais pour spe
terrible mais pourquoi on ne prend pas
plus de précautions parce que quand on
arrive sur des interventions et qu'on y
va de manière un peu musclée contre on
montre la puissance on accusait policier
alors c'est pas vrai a accusé de prendre
ces interpellations à venir correctement
quand on est armé s'il vous plaît moi je
dis pas que parce que on s'inquiète du
sort des policiers et qu'on trouve qu'il
faut un dur métier et qui est de la
violence on a un facho qui passa
comprends très bien qu'on s'inquiète
quand on voit toutes ces violences ainsi
on voit les policiers en plein la
tronche etc
j'ai juste que quand on soutient un
texte qui ciblent des gens quand même
parce que quand on lit bien le texte on
voit bien les ordres de banlieue
l'essonne mais j'en ai une certaine
religion les gens mais s'il faut lire le
guardian à l'expression valeurs
actuelles pas dans les moyens je
voudrais juste terminée voilà quand il
ya des choses qui doivent alors être de
manière oui alors dans la dot peut-être
pas mais vous vous prenez des exemples
par contre sur les pour lesquelles vous
dites il faut tirer sur les gens et je
crois que vous parlez aussi de l'allée
de l'heure actuelle ses coutures et
c'est pour ça que je réponds moi ce qui
m'embête c'est qu'effectivement on a
droit de se soucier de ça évidemment
faut que nous les politiques on trouve
des réponses ce n'est que par contre
quand c'est des gens qui utilisent la
détresse de cette police pour reprendre
des propositions qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses comme le fait qu'on puisse
laisser tirer sur les gens c'est
terrible et que quand quelqu'un comme
moi parce que dans ce pays c'est aussi
ça la réalité dit simplement vous comme
monsieur chouïa que oui la 99 % de gens
bien dans la police mais qui a aussi
quelques personnes qui ne vont pas du
tout cas aussi des choses à changer
les vidéos et que notre pays soit salie
présenter comme indépendant tifosi que
j'aime et intelligente on vous dit non
non non moi ce qui me gêne en fait c'est
qu'on se sert de dérapage de la police
n'a une entre la police pour ligue et
les uns contre les autres
collias j'ai tout ça au nom peuvent à
politiser la police la police et l'armée
d'ailleurs ne doivent défendre personne
à part la nation donc c'est ça qui me
gêne avec ça c'est qu'on politis tout ça
ne va pas être politisée mais ils disent
bien ils disent merde alors moi j'ai
honoré la question est claire esprit oui
alors c'est oui je comprends tout à fait
oui effectivement la colère des
militaires et de la police je suis très
choqué par l'ape l'utilisation politique
que vous en faites monsieur pardonnez
moi et effectivement il est un des noms
ce même l'utilisation de la politique et
d'esker et refuse quelques morts que ce
soit c'est un ras-le-bol généralisé
donc il veut refaire cette politisation
paris ne fait que regarder une demi
heure soit moi qui pensait que monsieur
o rien moi je me pose quand même une
question vous rendez compte quand même
de la violence qui est de plus en plus
importante dans notre pays de plus en
plus jeunes à regarder qui a tué le
policier avignon quand même il a 19 ans
ou à semblablement à bout portant il
vient à bout portant on parle de la
police dont on peut parler d'autre chose
terrible qui sont passés ces derniers
mois on l'est on les oublie vite hélas
parce que même une info chasse l'autre
samuel pâtit madame halimi est quand
même et une violence aujourd'hui en
france qui fait que oui je comprends ce
texte et 2
c'est quoi la solution parce qu'il va
falloir réagir très vite maintenant
antipollution par d'autres violences
parce que les problèmes de l'état
comment vous faites aujourd'hui pour
répondre à cette problème est bien de
travailler à l'état major ayant laissé
par les policiers explosive au delà j'ai
pas envie qu'on en fasse un débat
politique samedi dans une main politique
celle aux origines et les de dire oui
mais je voulais que ça moi je vous dire
comment c'est qui ce qu'on peut faire
pour éviter d'arriver une guerre civile
à nice message aux gens préfèrent le
demander à michel michel au jour
d'aujourd'hui l'urgence c'est que
l'appareil judiciaire fonctionne à
nouveau et qu'on extrait de la société
les personnes aujourd'hui qui crée un
trouble grave à l'ordre public alors ça
passera nous l'a dit sur le terrain
effectivement par une réforme de la
légitime défense mais ça passera
sur le plan judiciaire
déjà parent une réforme clair
aujourd'hui vous à un système de
confusion de peine qui est absolument
scandaleux vous avez des individus qui
ont commis 35 fraction il arrive devant
le juge on leur fait une confusion de
peine on leur fait un blu aux états unis
par exemple on a un système de cumul de
peines
vous prenez pour chaque peine que chaque
infraction vous avez commis vous avez la
peine qui va en adéquation il faut
aujourd'hui que les peines soient
appliquées quand j'entends par exemple
la porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur madame camille chase
alors elle est passée chez laurence
ferrari elle nous explique que
l'incarcération le tout carcéral n'est
pas la solution qu'il faut alors que
notre collègue d'un et tuer qu'il faut
lutter contre les le racisme dans la
police - le racisme dans la police ça
n'existe pas ou alors c'est l'un une
infime minorité comme dans toutes les
professions
mais encore une fois je prenais exemple
tout à l'heure par exemple un chirurgien
qui va rater son patient est-ce que vous
remettez en cause l'ensemble du système
de santé en france où l'ensemble de
l'hôpital
il peut chez nous les avoir
effectivement moi je l'ait jamais mais
là ça coûte une ville et le match ou via
et reverra plus aux finances mais voilà
encore une fois pour monsieur chouvier
assez dramatique
je le dis c'est dramatique mais pour
l'instant on ne sait pas il n'y a pas
encore eu les conclusions de l'enquêté
et je serais tenté de dire que quand on
voit la sévérité aujourd'hui de la
justice envers les fonctionnaires de
police notamment regarder dans la sphère
est clair mes collègues ont été
immédiatement suspecté du relanceur il y
avait 200 m ils avaient été
immédiatement placé en détention ou peut
supposer que si le dossier du fils de
monsieur chouf via était si étayé et
sicard et on ne peut supporter
j'aimerais qu'on va pas les faire
d'accord avec vous permettez moi
monsieur je pense que justement c'est
vraiment la présence de monsieur je vous
dis avec très importante bien sûr qu'il
ya une telle défiance sur la justice
mais aussi sur les enquêtes de police
il ya une bonne fois pour toutes il va
falloir qu'on met les choses au clair il
ya une sorte d'opacité on comprend pas
alors il ya des enquêtes on sait pas
c'est hyper long aux etats unis le
procès de georges frêche en un an
c'était bouclé on savait mais on aime on
ne sait pas où on est on est pour la
garer sur le lit gp à la main - servent
à faire parce que non tant que citoyen
on a l'impression qu'on sait pas on sait
pas par qui ces rondes il parle
pardonnez moi monsieur je ne connais pas
vraiment ou l'étonnant launay moi ça me
pose pas de problème vous voyez une
opacité qui finalement dessert tout le
monde et la police et les
tim de violence je vous dis je peux pas
mieux vous répondre nous notre
organisation syndicale le syndicat
france police de policiers en colère on
est favorable aujourd'hui à la
suppression de l'igpn est de revoir et
effectivement le mode de contrôle de la
police nationale donc je peux pas voir
en mieux moi ça me pose aucun problème
qu'on doit rendre des comptes et dieu
merci
la police doit rendre des comptes on est
dans une démocratie mais il faut pas si
vous voulez qu au nom de rendre des
comptes
ça on tombe dans le police bashing
permanent ou systématiquement sans avoir
l'étonnant les nationales et des
nouragues oscillant déjà le cas chez
converse compenser téléspectateurs tiens
oui à 77%
comprenez vous la colère des policiers
et militaires oui à 77%
c'est énorme 1 23% non